all right well let's bring in uh the
conservative mp david davis who is a
supporter of course of rishi sunak and
we'll talk a little bit about the
conservative leadership race in a moment
oh miss davis if we can but first i want
to just get your thoughts on what we're
seeing in taiwan nancy pelosi is there
the rhetoric coming from china has been
very severe we're seeing there got live
fire exercises and there's also been
this line in the past 24 hours or so
that if british mps were to go from the
foreign affairs select committee
there'll be severe consequences i mean
what do you think's happening right now
with the way that china's reacting well
this is a classical chinese pressure
play and i think the the lesson we learn
from ukraine with another dictatorial
country is you don't give into it um
it's better to
push now than to allow the situation to
get somewhere where it's going to be
military action
so i think uh i think we should uh we
should go ahead with a visit i'm afraid
i think
nancy pelosi did the right thing
in going uh and we should do the right
thing one of the problems with taiwan is
that it's not covered by an absolute
sort of nato style guarantee if there
was a nato style guarantee then the
risks would be much lower just as
ukraine didn't have a nato star
guarantee so you know we probably made a
historic mistake decades ago in not not
entrenching that because taiwan is a
free country and we can't allow taiwan
to be absorbed into what is in effect a
chinese empire now
so my view is um fray press the point
and deal with the consequences which
will probably be economic
you say economic but it's not guarantee
that would be economic because the the
chinese have threatened military
responses you know they're they're live
fire exercises are going on right now
and they're a nuclear superpower with a
man in charge of them who doesn't seem
very afraid to flex his military mind
well we had you know we had this debate
initially over russia and ukraine as
well and people were running afraid of
you know nuclear responses always never
going to be a nuclear response from
from uh
a man but much less a nuclear response
is still going to be terrible for the
reason for the world but there there is
there is this test is always going to
come at some level it's always going to
come at some point if we back down now
that will reward belligerent behavior
you know and the lesson down the
centuries is you mustn't reward
belligerent behavior you know we we you
know for the 1930s we turned a blind eye
to
all sorts of actions sedate and land and
so on by hitler uh and if we do that
with china they will keep pushing and
pushing and pushing until it comes a
point to which you uh you have to say
stop now better now where it's
saber rattling but not actual action uh
than than later i mean we truth be told
we have to find a complete reset of our
relationship with china we you know we
we depend on them anybody who's got an
iphone
depends on them and the for for the for
the manufacture of the iphone we depend
on vast amounts of economic activity
we've got to find a way
uh without doing ourselves enormous harm
finding a new relationship and i'm
afraid this is a part of that it's a
part of saying to china you can't always
get your own way in the south china sea
in taiwan and so on there will come a
point at which you if you want to stay
within the the
civilized nations you've got to come to
an agreement with your neighbour i mean
there was a bit of a reset with your
leadership rival back in the day wasn't
there wasn't called the golden period of
our relationship with china yeah david
cameron said i think i mean i think um
david cameron george osborne went too
far with two things with with china
partly because they got sort of punished
for seeing the dalai lama um
and and we put it remember after the
litvinyenko killing putin was then taken
to watch the judo by david cameron at
the the olympics i mean both i think
bad decisions and we now pay the
consequences because the other side
think we're weak you know and if and if
we keep telegraphing we're weak
what the bullies do they pick on the
weak kid in the playground and if we are
the weak kid in the playground then
we'll get picked on so last one on this
because i want to move on to leadership
but there is a pact in places orcas
australia the united states and britain
would you like to see that strengthened
you mentioned some kind of nato-style
province would you like to see that
strength well
yeah i think i think we've got to i mean
on taiwan in particular we've got to
think you know do we do we increase the
guarantee we can be absolutely certain
if we did that there would be a huge row
with china you know so is there a
stepwise way is the is there a uh
gentle is the wrong word but is there a
gentle way
to get to a better relationship and this
this will take a lot of thought and a
lot of talk amongst us and once we do it
no one must back down everybody must
stand together and so you've got to
really knit everyone together before you
start and that's what we should be doing
now really commit to it thank you very
much for your thoughts on that mr davis
let's move on to the leadership race you
would have seen that poll from you gov
just recently it makes you smile you
can't make wishes soon next month
sort of the enthusiasm shall we say of
the times because in the last three days
we've had we've had three polls right
these polls are really to be fair to the
pulse it's really difficult to do how do
you find tory members you know we don't
publish their names
and you ring somebody up while you're a
touring member someone might think well
i voted tori that makes me a twin no he
doesn't so you've got three polls uh one
today 28
behind one um yesterday more than that
whatever it is i mean something it's a
huge huge gas of 16 that's right the the
the one yesterday we're about five
points behind and and another one of
tory councillors who you can identify
and then one group you can which is bri
yeah evens you know
so who the devil knows as jake berry
said from the other side this morning
says there's only one poll that counts
it's the one that will happen after
about august the 11th where people start
sending their their ballots in and the
other thing to remember about these
polls is they're all done about five
days ago before
yesterday in particular when liz
declared she's going to save 8.8 billion
by
effectively restricting salaries i mean
cutting salaries is what the press say
but restricting salaries and not just of
civil servants but of doctors and nurses
and teachers and policemen and firemen
and so on and they didn't they did it
without thinking it through and i think
the public will make come to a view on
judgment on that that's very very
important in this process they said it
was misrepresented you're saying it
wasn't misrepresented no they accused
they first they started by accusing
journalists from misrepresenting and the
journalists quite properly then read
back their own
their their own presence very clearly
it was very very obvious and now they're
accusing us of misrepresenting well no
this is what they said what happened
well the p the people who misrepresented
them was themselves they didn't think
through look you don't have to feedback
was sitting there yesterday defending it
jacob rees-mogg was sitting right there
defending it yeah exactly now you know
they said they're going to save 8.8
billion
well you know
to save 8.8 billion by salary
restriction it needs to be a very very
big set of salaries the only way you
could do that is by including all those
processes and it's not the first time i
mean we had the same issue
with the the tax strategy i mean i am
probably one of the fiercest tax cutters
in the house of commons but i would
design the strategy so we didn't have to
have an increase in interest rates to
seven percent so the mortgages will be
eight nine and ten percent so you gain
if you're a normal person with a
mortgage you gain a few hundred pounds
on the tax you lose seven thousand
pounds on the mortgage you know you
they've got to i mean this is this is a
dress rehearsal for being a prime
minister right you can't afford to make
those sorts of judgmental errors and i
think that's one of the reasons i think
it's actually going to turn out to be
good that that the polling is delayed
slightly by week because people have
more time to see with both candidates
you know whether they think their
judgment is good whether they think
their instincts are good uh and and that
i think will favor my candidate
certainly i mean talking about judgement
then your mannerishing sooner did have
to you turn on his tax plans didn't he
wouldn't you say that
he was he was very clear yeah and those
early interactions with literature trust
that he was fiscally conservative he
wasn't going to cut any taxes yet he
said that their plans were fancy
economics two days later when he
realizes how popular it is among the
grassroots members he's like oh no we're
going to cut taxes to be fair to him
what he said at the beginning was we
will need to make a judgment about
what we do on helping it with energy
costs when we know more about it now
the upfront remember back in april was
to give 1200 pounds to the most
vulnerable people what the vat would do
is give another 160
so you're about 1360 but of course the
increased energy cost is much bigger
than that so he may well have to revisit
again i don't know he may well have to
revisit it again uh because you this
morning this very morning you've got
people calling for martin lewis and
others calling for further help so what
do you feel about that do you think
that's something that should be why
certainly we're gonna have to look at it
i mean the the the the the problem here
and this is an idea of a huge investment
of money in the poorest of the poorest
households i know with them
you know and
and one of the difficulties here is
it's a bit like the trade-off with with
liz's tax proposals
you save money on one front but then you
cost at least some people vast amounts
of money on another front with a
mortgage uh effect and so you've got
what you've got to do is think it
through carefully it's you know there's
a lot of mathematics to do i'm afraid in
this there's a lot of calculation to do
to work out how much headroom you've got
if you've got any left at all what you
do whether it whether borrowing for it
is worthwhile or whether that will drive
the pound down and cause more inflation
you see it's a complicated thing and it
shouldn't be done by dutch auction this
is one of my things you know i'm very
very very keen on tax cuts but i want
you know i want it to be done in a
calculated way in a sensible way so it's
in the national interest not just the
interest of the leadership contender so
liz truster's maths are just not good
enough that's what you're saying well
they haven't been i'm afraid on the on
the on these two very very big issues
enormous issues there'll be massive
weaknesses in each now she quite rightly
you turn i mean i don't make a big deal
of you turning i think if you make a
mistake back off you know don't do it um
you know and there's been plenty of
times in governments in the bath
governments i've been a member of where
we've had to change our mind is the nice
way to put it so that that's a good
thing but you know the fear is you know
that when you're when you're a prime
minister i mean people often don't think
through you promised you come in you get
up first you read all papers first
meeting in the morning eight o'clock how
you deal with the sort of press crisis
of the day what you said terrible about
the prime minister whatever how we're
going to respond to it then at nine you
may have a national security meeting and
deal with an issue with the russians or
whatever then at 10 you may have the the
uh
the cabinet meeting and deal with three
other big issues you don't have time
to deliberate your instincts and your
judgment are incredibly important and
that's what's being tested in this
process i mean that you're saying that
her instincts and judgment are way off
and she's not well no what i'm saying no
no i'm very careful i've always been
very careful about not attacking i mean
you know any at any point in this legion
process what i'm saying is the public
but
in the most immediate insensitory party
members would
draw their own conclusions about who is
going to have the right instincts the
right judgment to be prime minister
remember this is a much much bigger job
than being a cabinet minister it really
is it's very hard to to to get across
how big the step is and so we all we've
got is a few weeks to say has this
person got the capability to transform
into what we want